a good chunk of time has passed since
the events of the first film and we do
get the broad Strokes for what happened
between foam 1 and film 2 for your
characters but I was wondering are there
any like smaller backstory details or
personal experiences that you came up
with that we could at least now feel
informing your performance Jim gave us a
script of 1.5
shows the time between Avatar and Avatar
way of water and he wrote a full script
oh wow
um and gave it to me and said look read
this this is we'll fill in the blanks of
what Jake's been doing and I said when
do we shoot this one because this is
amazing he goes no no that's just
someone I wrote over the past year to
give you his backstory and then I lend
it to Zoe it was amazing I think you
lost it but um
are there any specific details you can
share it was more about what they went
through as a couple because you know the
the relationship was evolved at the at
the end of the first one but this was
about literally then the war continued
having the kids and consummating and
stuff like that and the war and so it
was it gave us a good jumping off point
of where they were at not that his plan
isn't ambitious enough but like you made
these next movies and then you go back
and you make a series of 1.5 yeah it's
crazy that he wrote that but he needed
that to to just know where Pandora had
evolved to and where this love story
exactly yeah oh I love it I want to know
everything
um I was reading a quote that James had
said about himself and he said he tried
to be he tried to be more emotionally
present for the team on this movie I was
wondering could you both feel that and
if so how has his approach as an actor's
director changed oh my
he is he is the best actors director
there is
there is a sense of just family you know
uh the second time around that felt to
me like the natural progression of what
had started back in 2006 2007.
um Jim is like a fine wine he just gets
better in time you know I mean like just
keeps having me better and better and
better and now that he's plant-based oh
my God forget about it
more energy
um it was wonderful I think that back in
2006 there was this great deal of
pressure to prove this concept this was
something that was conceived at a thin
air that he just couldn't avoid uh just
keeping it for himself he had to
externalize this and and I think it was
hard for all of us to try to understand
what was in his mind and little by
little that's why he kept collaborating
with us and showing us every process of
it in order for us to understand what
was in his you know what he was
envisioning by Avatar way of water
um
there is no need to prove there was no
pressure it was it was just about
following your heart getting to go back
to Pandora and I think that everybody
was just like you know bracing
themselves like let's go I have another
quote for you now so I was reading an
interview that Jamie had done and I want
to get this right he specifically said
James will either celebrate you or be
your biggest critic if he sees a problem
he's going to let you know about it but
then he goes on to explain that there
was once a discussion where the
discussion between you and James almost
broke down and it ended in you needing
to meditate me now that I've eaten yeah
now that I've seen the movie can you
pinpoint what that scene was and then
maybe how you overcame and collaborated
on whatever the challenge was it might
have been underwater sometime because
see any you can't communicate underwater
to be honest and you can hear Jim
underwater directing so sometimes you
get a bit confused of what what's going
on so I don't think it was actually a
mediation between any conflict I think
it was more or less trying to navigate
what we're being told underwater and how
to how to do that and Jamie going
I think it was more along those lines
fair enough yeah and then a conflict and
here's a and here's here's the wonderful
thing about working with someone like
like Jim Jim is expecting you to come
with your firm beliefs of what in what
you're doing
and yes there is passionate discourses
that have everything to do with our
project because everybody walks in with
a very selfless mindset but the moment
he yells that's a wrap
nothing is taken home with you because
it's never about it never gets personal
so there there is a lot of passion when
you firmly believe in who your character
is and where you are and what you're
doing but he kind of goes
this is where you need to be in order
for you to get here we're gonna work and
he welcomes it he's like come come come
come come but at the end like he's still
the boss you know and and uh those kind
of experiences only make this project
this story better not an easy batch of
qualities to balance but it seems like
he's an expert at it and I think it pays
off in this movie quite a bit absolutely
congratulations thank you for your time
today